on the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
the new head coach of notre dame
football marcus freeman here on the rich
eisen show how you doing coach
i'm doing great rich how you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you
congratulations um thank you you are
welcome let's get right down to it the
most important question i could ask you
is die hard a christmas movie coach what
do you think is he
is diehard a christmas movie coach of
notre dame football absolutely
coach
i'm gonna run through a brick wall right
now i'm gonna play like a champion today
you really feel that way
you've got six children do you show this
to your children and say this is a
christmas movie coach is that what you
do you know we watch it during christmas
time so i would consider it a christmas
movie in this discussion absolutely
makes sense to me all right all right
you uh so does that make the coach a die
hard truther or am i or am i am i the
die hard uh conspiracy theorist is that
what i'm doing right now yeah you're on
the conspiracy nobody's asked you that
yet in your media tour yet huh this is
the i'm the first to do that at least
right that's the first for sure that's
the first okay how about this have you
seen rudy have you seen the movie rudy
multiple times
now you made my kids watch it then the
day i was named defensive coordinator at
notre dame my kids watched it so i've
watched it multiple times
okay so you're you're you are hired from
cincinnati you go to notre dame and this
is not too long ago right it was uh just
at the top of this year correct when
this happened
11 months ago what a ride okay so then
you so you you're like i i have now been
hired by notre dame we're watching rudy
okay no doubt
no doubt i got him listen i got him some
some notre dame gear and i had to
convince him like this is this is the
greatest thing ever known to man and so
the first thing we had to do was we had
to watch the movie rudy and they were
all in after we watched that oh
my gosh
have you spoken to the actual rudy since
you're you're not i have not but our
officer coordinator tommy reeve said he
is going to facilitate facilitate that
introduction so uh i'm sure at some
point here soon i'll get a chance to
beat him i am sure he will clear his
schedule to talk to you sir i am i'm
sure and so meanwhile you're you're
flying around the country recruiting
people all about heart right five foot
nothing you're you're recruiting rudy's
now correct that's that's what you're
going for right now yeah that's probably
not the
number one
guy we're gonna be recruiting you know i
would love the heart
you know the heart aspect of it yes i
agree with that but the the size the
speed uh we're looking for a little bit
more elite talent you're not used to
wearing green very much are you in your
life football life marcus freeman right
no
no no this was the uh first time i've
ever put on my words
so so let's let's walk into this here uh
i i mean can you even believe your year
i mean you're hired as a defensive
coordinator from cincinnati and now
you're the head coach of the
notre dame fighting irish coach it's
kind of crazy yeah
yeah it is would you imagine that you
would be the head coach of notre dame 11
months ago or 11 days ago absolutely not
obviously this is the one of the premier
head coaching jobs in all college
football and so
you know at times i have those moments
where i say wow you're the head coach at
notre dame and then
soon thereafter i'm in another household
or i'm recruiting another kid or i'm
talking to somebody else and so you
don't have much time to think about it
um but there are those surreal moments
that you just go back and you
appreciative of the opportunity you have
and it's kind of it's kind of wild as
well um you know obviously that you know
you mentioned 11 days ago
even right so did you get any indication
throughout the year that coach kelly had
wanderlust or had soured on an
experience potentially um at notre dame
at all no not at all not one bit and
if anything it was more confirmation
that he was never going to leave this
place so
um i was just as surprised as anybody
else
in the country other than maybe coach
kelly
and that call came just when like a week
ago
maybe yesterday right it was it was a
monday
when he called me i was in high school
seeing a committed kid and and
i missed five phone calls and i said
okay i need to go outside and return
coach kelly's phone call and i did and
he told me that
he was taking the job at lsu and
and wanted me to to come be as deep as a
coordinator and so
at that moment when you say i'm gonna be
the head coach of lsu my first thought
was oh shoot i need a job i don't know
who's gonna be the next head coach at
notre dame and he said would you come i
said absolutely i said just let me ask
my wife and from that moment um when i
said let me ask my wife has been just a
whirlwind of transition from me to being
deep as a coordinator uh maybe at notre
dame maybe at lsu to now head coach at
notre dame yeah what walk me through how
your head must have been swimming you're
in a high school talking to a committed
kid
did you say anything to that kid at the
moment i mean like what do you do like
how do you know i prepared for you
yeah i walked outside to talk to him and
and
you know what i did was i i kind of um
called my wife and said wow this just
happened yeah um
and i went to the kids house and then
it's the report started coming out you
know started hitting twitter and all
these things and and
this wasn't within hours this was within
hours that it was happening and so
um by the time i got home you know it
was
um kind of like i don't know what's
going to happen and so
i got a couple phone calls that monday
night from people that um are really
involved with notre dame football that
kind of made me say oh hold on is this
really a possibility that i might be
named head coach and from that point
till when they named me head coach um it
was a constant communication with notre
dame and with different people that are
affiliated with our football program in
our university well it's pretty cool
they so they
i imagine with all these moving parts
the school reached out to you right away
to start giving you an indication that
you were the guy right i mean they
didn't see no dilly dally at all i'd
imagine no i got a call um at some point
maybe late on that monday or tuesday i
can't remember i said hey
would you be interested in interviewing
for this position and i said absolutely
and so from that moment i was like oh is
this real i mean they could just be
interviewing me just to say they're
interviewing me and uh but that
obviously interview turned into a um an
opportunity where they offered me the
head coaching position
did you who else did you reach out to i
mean who else is in your in your inner
circle other than than your wife and
well in this process
i talked to a couple first time um
you know
head coaches that i have known um one
being mike grebel he's an ohio state guy
i played ohio state and i know brave
bewell and i'm like tell me what what is
it going to be like what are they going
to ask me what what do you say sometimes
when they say hey are you ready
and he was honest braves was honest like
hey we're never you're never ready until
you get the opportunity to do it you
learn on the fly and so um he kind of
made me feel a little bit
better about hey just go in there and be
yourself and that's the the advice i've
gotten from everybody from ryan day to
luke pickle to jim tressel and guys that
i'm that i know just from my ohio
sickness today you're going to have to
be yourself you cannot be brian kelly
you cannot be luke fickle you can't be
jim trustling you've got to be marcus
freeman and understand that you have to
do this thing
with whatever
characteristics that you did as a
defense coordinator whatever
characteristics you had as a leader as a
linebacker's coach you're going to have
to be that same person but now you're in
charge of an entire
football program or entire notre dame
organization
well clearly you've taken that advice to
to heart marcus freeman because the
video that was sent out by the school of
you being introduced
to the players
in your suit and then you come in it was
it was awesome i mean that was a what
was that like for you i mean i'm just
sitting watching it in the palm of my
hand on my phone but what was that
moment like for you
it was very surreal it was it was it
seemed like a long time comment because
i had known for probably 24 hours
before that moment that hey this this is
really happening like it's going down
and so
i was told hey you can't talk to anybody
don't communicate like you stay in your
home and kind of let's let's kind of
let's go through all the hr stuff that
has to be done before we can you know
present you to the team and so um it was
like just a a you know a siren leak just
to go be around your guys and that's all
i want to do man i wanted to give much a
chance to hug them and be around them
and tell them thank you because they're
the ones that kind of open this window
they're the ones that
you know kind of went to the a.d and
said hey we
feel
as a football team that hey
we want this culture that we built to
stay
the way it is we we think we have the
best candidate in house and and then it
was the ad and the president
you know there then they had to do their
interviews and they had to figure out
their nationwide search hey what was the
best
leader for this program and and they
were the ones that finally made that
decision and uh here we are some of the
players did do that huh they did
actually do that yeah
yeah yeah and and the aed met with uh
jack swarberg he met with our captains
and
and he said you know that was one of the
most impactful times that he's ever had
as maybe when they were so passionate
about you know owning their culture and
owning the leadership and owning hey
we feel like this is what's best we feel
like we know what's best we've won 11
games we've won we've sustained this
excellence and it's not because of a one
person and um they went to bat for me
and then you know again
thank you i'm so thankful and grateful
for the players but but then for jax
forward and father jenkins to actually
make the decision to do it you know to
interview me and do a nationwide search
and just say you know what hey
let's let's make the decision that's
what i'm probably doing yeah and and i
also was thinking too and i was watching
that marcus freeman head coach of notre
dame football here on the rich eisen
show i'm assuming it was in that same
room that we saw on that video in that
same spot
that just what 24 or 48 hours before
brian kelly called him by the way at 7
00 a.m to come in to to hear from him
one last time and
those same guys now it seemed like an
immense amount of relief to see you
walking in and the celebration because i
imagine as well
you you have an immense responsibility
to these young men you're you're not
just a coach you're you're a healer in a
way would you agree with that yeah you
you got to continue your job as leaders
continue to put these guys in the best
situation to be successful on the
football field tactically and
technically but also to be the one that
gives these young people hope like
they have to look at you and believe
that you're going to be the reason a
reason of why they are in a position to
have success and so
that's my job as the head coach of this
team is continue to keep us together
continue to get us to believe that hey
the things we're doing on the field and
in the meetings rooms and in the weight
rooms are going to be the reasons why we
have success
marcus freeman here on the rich eisen
show now you had mentioned before you
spoke to vrabel and obviously fickle who
was the guy who gave you the gig at
cincinnati right so
um and uh and tressel from you know
buckeye where you played you said you
were an uh an ohio state guy is that the
same as the ohio state
i'm confused i think there's there's
there's some people maybe
outside the program that love to use
that term d i'm i'm an ohio state guy
you know and that's what hey man and i
don't
we don't try to i don't try to make it
seem like we're anything different than
okay anybody else all right i went to
ohio state okay so you're not this is
not going to become the notre dame
university all right
no okay the university of notre dame
okay that will not happen
and i'm assuming because you you you
know my background i would assume i
don't know if you do or not okay good
so so you were rooting for you were
rooting for iowa saturday night weren't
you you were right
i
i
was
we're putting cards in the table it's
not that way all the cards are on the
table here okay so you were all right
can do do you think our
my alma mater and in your school could
play each other a little sooner than
what we got going on what do you think
can we get back on
what do you think here what do you think
you know it it could possibly happen who
knows no but you know my focus is
getting this team ready for yeah
you should go up to him and say you know
you should go to go up to gundy and say
you're not yet 40 so you're not
technically a man can you do that when
you go up there can you have fun with
him
technically you know what i might have
to mention that
i'm just trying to leave you better than
when i found you and even though
everything seems to be going great for
you so um i'm a pleasure to have met you
um sir
congratulations what a ride for you and
your family my gosh going from hey kids
this is rudy this is dad's new uh uh
place of business to you running the
program within a matter of uh months is
remarkable there's really not much
like that so uh congratulations to you
and yours oh thanks man i really
appreciate it i look forward to being
back on here soon no i appreciate you
saying that and and good luck traveling
the country and and getting uh the kids
that you're looking for and so um you
know uh and congratulations to your
family this is a this is a big moment
for you guys so have a good holiday
thank you i appreciate it rich you bet
it that's marcus freeman head coach of
notre dame football nice right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here